for a decent period of time miles teller
was at the top of the hollywood totem
pole but he's mostly been m.i.a
as of late as it turns out his absence
from the spotlight can be attributed to
a few different factors
some of which are more innocuous than
others despite his recent break from the
silver screen
miles teller isn't done exercising his
acting chops just yet back in 2018
news broke that the actor had been cast
as bradley rooster bradshaw in the
upcoming film
top gun maverick bradley is the son of
goose from the original movie and he
appears to be following in his father's
footsteps by becoming a pilot
it's the kind of big budget production
teller needed after
two of his higher profile projects
fantastic four
and the divergent series allegiant
failed to make a big impression at the
box office
the main problem is that top gun
maverick keeps getting pushed back
it was originally supposed to come out
back in 2019 but was delayed into 2020
and we all know what happened at that
point paramount pushed top gun maverick
along with most of its other offerings
into 2021 and beyond
so that audiences would be able to
experience big screen spectacle
from the comfort of a movie theater
without worrying about coronavirus
in the meantime fans could see the actor
in the 2019
amazon original series too old to die
young but that only lasted a single
season
still going a couple years between films
for a burgeoning young star is pretty
unusual
and his perceived persona may have
played a role in that
in 2015 esquire wanted to do a cover
story on teller
pretty standard stuff especially given
the fact he had just starred in a major
comic book adaptation with fantastic
four
so you would think teller would be on
his best behavior unfortunately
here's the first line of the article in
question you're sitting across from
miles teller at the luminary restaurant
in atlanta and trying to figure out if
he is
wow rude while the esquire piece
does complement his body of work most
people were too distracted by how much
teller came across
as to put it lightly a jerk salon went
so far as to gather some choice quotes
from the cover story that didn't exactly
paint the actor in the best light
such as when he compared a highball
glass to a part of his anatomy
or when he made a distasteful joke when
calling the reporter an uber
it wasn't the best look for the
up-and-coming actor but he didn't seem
to pay it much mind
he would later tell vulture people
outside of the business will think of me
however they want
but i want people inside the business to
see everything i can do
i gotta get moving even when the
public's perception of you changes ever
so slightly
one good role can turn everything around
after coming off the immense success of
whiplash
teller was set to reunite with director
damian chazelle
for his next film the academy award
darling la la land
teller was supposed to have the lead
role that would eventually go to ryan
gosling
emma watson who was originally attached
to star in the role that went to emma
stone
also had to drop out due to scheduling
conflicts with beauty and the beast
teller's departure is a bit murkier but
as he would tell esquire
i got a call from my agent saying hey i
just got a call from lionsgate damien
told them that he no longer thinks
you're creatively right for the project
he's moving on without you the actor
elaborated on his departure somewhat in
his later interview with vulture a
couple people know the truth
i'll go to my grave knowing that when
push came to shove i expressed
extreme loyalty to damien and that movie
that's sort of all i can say
with a missed chance to show off his
singing prowess and star in another best
picture nominee we can't help but wonder
if teller spends any sleepless nights
thinking about what would have happened
if la la land made it onto his resume
that is dumb
no no no no
never teller got himself a bad boy
reputation in the aftermath of his
esquire interview and that image was
only further cemented when he got into a
bit of a rough spot with johnny law
an initial report from e news suggested
the actor had been arrested for walking
around intoxicated in san diego
later teller took to twitter to give his
side of the story
went down to sd to see my buddy before
he deployed i wasn't arrested
i was detained because there was no
evidence to charge me with a crime
he posted a follow-up tweet stating
don't believe everything you read
especially from a third-party
entertainment news source trying to get
clicks
appreciate the concern regardless of
what actually transpired that evening
the bad press certainly didn't help with
his image while we won't know how much
the incident
affected his ability to land work if at
all it appeared from the outside to be
just one more questionable decision on
his part
i don't care i'm getting wasted of
course
the main reason teller may have kept a
lower profile in recent years is due to
the fact he's too busy
enjoying life with his wife model kelly
sperry
the two have been together since 2013.
they got engaged in 2017
and then tied the knot roughly two years
later on september 1st
2019. teller seems to love married life
if a recent interview with men's health
is anything to go by
once you get married and you make that
ultimate commitment life is just
a lot less stressful you just know that
person is always going to be there
while he may have enjoyed the down time
don't expect teller to go away anytime
soon it seems he isn't sweating the gap
in his filmography as he goes on to say
i'm not one of those people who worry
about if people don't see me every six
months
i don't feel like my career is dying
it's going to happen when it happens and
that's fine
in addition to having top gun maverick
on the horizon he's also attached to
other upcoming films
including escape from spider head flag
day and the fence
after a hectic few years maybe some
downtime is precisely what the star
needed
fortunately we can expect to see plenty
of teller in the very near future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you